欸，你可能沒想到，中國一家傳統餃子店，現在竟然成了他們那邊 AI 落地的典範。這真的很出乎意料，對吧？
餃子店用 AI？這怎麼說呢？我第一時間想到的是，是不是用機器人包餃子那種？但如果是，那跟我們平常理解的「AI 應用」好像又不完全一樣。這成本划算嗎？
不是機器人包餃子那種。這家店叫「金谷園」，他們老闆李波，41歲，自己開發了一個 AI 技能。你可以把它想像成一個小程式，讓客人的個人 AI 助理可以直接跟餃子店互動。
喔？個人 AI 助理？你是說，像Siri或Google Assistant那種？這怎麼跟餃子店串起來？一般客人會習慣這樣點餐嗎？
嗯，其實概念有點像。這個 AI 技能是讓用戶可以直接透過他們的 AI 代理，查詢菜單、尋求推薦，甚至排隊。李波是看到這種「代理式 AI 工具」越來越受歡迎，才在今年四月開發出來的。
讓 AI 代理排隊？這點我是信了，畢竟現在很多人習慣用手機預約。但查詢菜單、尋求推薦，這些資訊直接看菜單或問店員不是更快嗎？為什麼要繞彎子透過 AI 代理？
他們老闆的想法是，未來大家都會讓 AI 助理規劃日常生活，包括吃什麼。他希望金谷園能成為這個未來的一部分。而且，他還引用了鄧小平的話：「科學技術是第一生產力。」他覺得要永遠圍繞最先進的生產力。
「科學技術是第一生產力」，這句倒是很有意思。所以他的核心想法是，即便現在用起來可能沒那麼方便，但這是趨勢，必須先卡位？這模式撐得久嗎？
沒錯，他自己也承認，這個 AI 技能帶來更多的是媒體關注，實際使用量可能沒那麼高。但他很自豪能成為 AI 應用的榜樣。他覺得就像蒸汽機剛出來時，大家覺得它不如馬，但最終汽車還是贏了。
這點其實不容易做到，很多小店主會覺得成本、技術門檻高。他一個餃子店老闆，怎麼有能力開發 AI 技能？
他其實是學電信工程的。2010年碩士畢業後，雖然沒有當工程師，而是開了旅館、賣甜點，最後才跟餃子師傅合作開了這家金谷園。所以他有技術背景，是老本行重新點燃了他的科技熱情。
原來如此，有技術底子的人，做起來確實會比較有優勢。但對於一般沒有技術背景的中小企業主來說，想學這種模式，是不是會遇到很大的阻礙？
我覺得他用阿里雲的程式碼工具 Qoder  vibe-code 了一個網站，用來追蹤兩家分店的排隊狀況，這點就很有參考價值。這表示不一定需要從零開始開發，藉助現有工具也能實現。
那如果我是創業者或主管，可以從這裡學到什麼？感覺就是「提早佈局」和「擁抱新技術」？
其實我覺得，更深一層的是，他挑戰了我們對傳統產業的想像。他證明了即使是像餃子店這樣低技術門檻的產業，也能透過科技實現效率革新和顧客體驗升級，不只停留在概念層面。
但這會不會是中國特有的現象？原文有提到，中國人對 AI 的接受度很高，甚至有調查顯示他們對 AI 的興奮度是最高的。在台灣或西方社會，大家可能更擔心 AI 帶來的工作取代。
這點你是對的，原文確實有提到中國人「渴望採用 AI」。但在美國，小商家就比較不張揚自己用 AI。不過我覺得，對我們一般上班族來說，這件事的啟發是，即使在一個看似跟 AI 無關的領域，你還是可以找到跟新技術結合的機會。
意思是，不要先自我設限，覺得我的工作性質不可能跟 AI 有關？要主動去思考各種可能性？
對，就是這個意思。就像李波老闆一樣，即使開餃子店，他仍然會去想，AI 怎麼能幫他的生意。我們也可以把這個概念帶入自己的工作或生活，看看哪些地方可以用新的工具去優化。
總結來說，就是不要等技術成熟才行動，要像個探險家一樣，即便現在效果不佳，也要願意嘗試。
沒錯，就像李波說的：「總要有人開始用它，即便它現在還不是那麼好。」這好像也提醒了我們，有時候第一個吃螃蟹的人，不一定是要把螃蟹料理到完美，而是願意去嘗試，讓它有被完善的可能。